I don't think that decisions need to
take a long time as we've progressed in
business our speed of decision making
has decreased just basically put
decisions in two buckets which is is it
a reversible decision or irreversible
decision if it is irreversible to what
degree is it irreversible having a kid
very irreversible marriage less
irreversible but also tough to get out
of there you know where we're gonna go
for lunch today irreversible but very
low stake partially other people
struggle with it so much because it is
an irreversible decision but it also
doesn't matter it's a reversible
decision side then those ones we just
say I like using the term what's my best
bad guess it sets the bar Lower for the
expedition of yourself and others just
saying hey this is my best bad idea and
we only commit to one thesis at
acquisition.com and everything we do
which is test and iterate we're not
committing to this path we're committing
to test and iterate and this is just the
first test and so seeing it that way and
it makes it just a tiny test on a much
bigger process that we're all aligned
with always